believe that removing the threat of an
Iranian bomb which we are confident this
agreement does while allowing Iran to
re-engage with the international
community is the best and perhaps the
only way to build over time the trust
that will allow a dialogue on the many
other issues we have with Iran and I
look forward to a constructive
discussion with you this afternoon so
the question I have is would it not make
sense for your government and the other
powers of the p5 plus one to one condemn
powerfully this expression of
anti-semitism this desire to annihilate
the Jewish state and to demand that Iran
cease and desist there's such genocidal
calls and actions well I'm looking
forward to that discussion mr. prime
minister if I may just respond briefly I
understand your concerns but we have
always been clear that this deal was
about the nucleophile the sanctions
regime is around Iran's illegal nuclear
activities thank you
you want another bounce or the wall go
on you're gonna have to do it anyway so
no government on the continent they
openly call for our destruction and they
work for our destruction while you give
them sanctions relief
you're not merely addressing I think in
a flawed way their nuclear file what
you're doing is also giving them
hundreds of billions of dollars which
they can fuel unrestricted into their
war machine into their terror activities
would you like to continue
thank you